supongo que este es un muy buen momento
como como cualquier otro para aprender
acerca de probablemente lo que la
mayoría de la gente se enfoca más cuando
analiza una compañía y es el estado de
resultados el estado de resultados es
uno de los estados financieros que vas a
querer ver cuando analizas una compañía
el otro es la hoja de balance la hoja de
balance está la he dibujado a un montón
en muchos ejemplos de banca y así y
bueno en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo se
relacionan estos dos verdad hay uno
último que se llama el estado de flujos
de efectivo de flujos de efectivo
después nos vamos a enfocar en ese más
tarde porque pues tiene un poquito más
de detallitos pero bueno el estado de
resultados literalmente dice cuánto ganó
una compañía en un periodo dado siempre
tiene que ver con un periodo puede ser
un periodo anual por ejemplo un estado
de resultados anual para el año 2008 o
podría ser trimestral verdad usualmente
son los que ves pero a lo mejor te
puedas encontrar con estados de
resultados mensuales o semestrales en
fin hay de varios tipos
el formato general es muy consistente
hay un poco de variación dependiendo de
la industria pero en este vídeo quiero
hablar así de un estado de resultados
muy sencillo de una compañía que vende
artesanías entonces la primera cosa que
haces cuando vendes artesanías es que
las haces y las vendes verdad le das al
cliente una artesanía y a cambio el
cliente te da algo de dinero ese dinero
que te da y bueno ahorita no me voy a
meter mucho con los tecnicismos verdad
se considera un ingreso de ventas
voy a poner así ventas o ingresos de
ventas literalmente es el dinero que te
dan en una cierta cantidad de tiempo
entonces cuando haya algunos contadores
que digan no no no es que no esté ese
dinero es el dinero que ganaste bueno si
eso es cierto pero ahorita con el fin de
seguir la discusión así más tranquilita
vamos a suponer que en cuanto das una
artesanía ya ganaste el dinero ahora eso
ahí es dinero por ventas después vamos a
hablar cómo hacer la compañía la
contabilidad de esto pero por el momento
vamos a decir que las ventas en este
periodo digamos en 2008 digamos que las
ventas fueron de pues 3
3 millones de pesos en artesanías va
entonces déjame escribirlo por aquí en
algún lugar entonces supongamos que es 3
millones de pesos ahora muchas veces
cuando veas estados de resultados para
compañías por ejemplo en yahoo
puedes verlo ahorita en vez de ver tres
millones vas a ver nada más tres mil y
vas a decir buffet esta compañía vende
bien poquito pero no sé es más o menos
una manera estándar de hacer las cosas
una convención de escribir los números
en miles entonces tres mil sería tres
mil miles que sería tres millones para
compañías muy grandes algunas veces se
escriben en millones es decir escriben
tres millones serían tres mil millones
es muchísimo pero bueno después vamos a
ver algunos estados de resultados reales
espero que en un futuro no muy lejano
bueno estoy acá es cuánto dinero nos
dieron por las artesanías pero esto pues
no es la utilidad de verdad porque pues
porque hay costos que se hicieron para
hacer estas artesanías no es como que
alguien llegó me regaló 3 millones y ya
hay son 3 millones los meto en el banco
y no voy a mi casa a descansar así no
funcionan las cosas entonces la primera
cosa que que se suele ver en un estado
de resultado
el costo verdad bueno lo que viene
después de las ventas es el costo déjame
poner todos los costos en rosa mexicano
todos los gastos entonces está digamos
el costo de ventas no de ventas no más
bien de bienes vendidos entonces el
costo de bienes vendidos esto
literalmente es bueno es dos cosas hay
un costo variable que es cada artesanía
pudo haber usado cierta cantidad no sé
de madera o de energía para producir la
lo mejor un poco de pintura si es una
artesanía pintada entonces el costo de
bienes vendidos literalmente es cuánto
costo pues comprar la madera la pintura
y pues pagar la electricidad para hacer
esos tres millones tres millones de
pesos en artesanías además de los costos
variables hay costos fijos por ejemplo
de que la fábrica esté abierta por todos
los días del año y eso cuesta lo mismo
sin importar cuántas artesanías se hagan
después nos detenemos en los detalles
pero básicamente supongamos que ahorita
todos los costos fueron de un millón de
pesos para hacer las artesanías algunas
veces cuando alguien te dice que un
costo de un millón lo pone con el
positivo yo no voy a poner con negativo
es un millón para acordarme que es un
gasto cualquier cosa que quite ingreso
le voy a poner menos todo lo que le
aumente le voy a poner más eso no es la
convención usual pero bueno si algunos
dicen como ya es un millón y es un costo
es negativo no sea o sea creo que es el
punto ahorita yo lo voy a poner con
signo menos en fin
entonces si restamos estas dos cosas y
restamos el costo del ingreso de ventas
o bueno si sumas estos dos porque el
segundo y es negativo entonces tienes tu
utilidad bruta utilidad
blood
y en este caso sería que pues es 3 menos
12 millones de pesos 2 millones de pesos
este número de aquí te dice cuánto
dinero hiciste cuánto dinero ganaste
bueno cuánta utilidad hiciste
simplemente vendiendo las artesanías
entonces usualmente mientras más
artesanías vendas en casi todas las
circunstancias este número se va a
volver más grande entonces está de acá
es tu utilidad antes de los otros gastos
que tienes que hacer hay otros gastos
verdad hay impuestos este el salario del
sillón y el salario del si aún no puede
estar acá verdad no podemos considerar
el salario del cio como costo de bienes
vendidos porque usualmente el director
general no está parado en la fábrica
haciendo artesanías bueno entonces el
salario de ciu va por otro lado también
hay que pagarle a las oficinas que están
en el rascacielos bien bonito y los
gastos de marketing para que la gente se
anime a comprar las artesanías bueno
todos esos gastos vienen en las
siguientes líneas a veces vienen
separados por tipo por ejemplo podría
decir
gastos de marketing con costos de
marketing algunas veces también tienes
que pagarle a personas de ventas verdad
a lo mejor tienes por aquí un costo de
ventas y luego hay otras cosas como pues
no sé la oficina corporativa o el
salario del siguió los auditores los
contadores todo eso que vamos a ponerlo
como general debería ponerlo todo en
color rosa mexicano verdad todo esto son
gastos marketing ventas en eje a ser
generales y administrativos entonces son
gastos generales y administrativos
algunas veces puedes ver los escritos
como bg ya lo cual es una abreviación
para ventas generales y administrativos
ventas son cosas como no sé las
comisiones que se le paga a las personas
de ventas o el costo de tener vendedores
por todo el país teniendo cenas de
negocios vaya a todo lo de ventas por
otro lado general y administrativo es
las personas que están en el edificio
pues ya sabes administrando haciendo
cuentas auditorías todo eso para correr
el negocio pero ahorita inventándome los
números sobre la marcha vamos a poner
que son 500 mil de marketing 500 mil
fusión menos porque quiero acordarme que
es un gasto en otros modelos lo vas a
ver con positivo porque ya es un gasto
de ventas supongamos que aquí nada más
es general y administrativos voy a poner
ventas aparte pero digamos que de ventas
es no sé digamos 200 mil 200 mil pesos y
generales y administrativos le voy a
poner que son 300 mil 300 mil pesos muy
bien entonces aquí llegamos a lo
siguiente ahora estamos listos para
determinar cuánto dinero hicieron las
operaciones de este negocio esto de aquí
se le conoce como utilidad operativa o
utilidad de operación de operación es
muy importante prestar atención a esto
porque una compañía puede decir a una
compañía hizo tanto entonces vas a
escuchar estos números mucha utilidad
neta utilidad bruta utilidad operativa
es muy difícil entender estos si uno no
entiende la distinción porque todos
tienen la palabra utilidad pero que es
bruto que es operativo aquí vamos a ver
qué son cosas muy distintas vamos a ver
cuánto es el número antes de que me vaya
por la tangente
de las diferencias pero a ver es dos
millones menos a ver son 500 menos igual
creo que dice que los números quedarán
super fáciles la utilidad operativa es
de un millón de pesos un millón de pesos
entonces ya tenemos pues algunos
detallitos con respecto a utilidades
verdad hice dos millones simplemente
vendiendo las artesanías pero cuando
quitamos todo lo de la compañía con
respecto a marketing ventas general y
administrativo
nada más nos quedan un millón de pesos
esto de aquí es la utilidad de las
operaciones de la compañía o bien se
podría decir del activo o de los
negocios que realiza la compañía esto es
lo que genera pero podemos ver y ya he
dibujado muchas hojas de balance a lo
mejor esto sea un buen momento de
dibujarla entonces tenemos a la
izquierda del activo de la compañía los
los activos pues después vamos a hablar
un poco más de activo del valor de
empresa hay detallitos que tenemos que
cuidar pero esencialmente es la compañía
por sí misma entonces antes de pensar
cómo se pagaron los bienes de la
compañía aquí tenemos la compañía por sí
misma el activo justo los activos son
los que están generando
y acá están generando la utilidad
operativa y eso es algo muy importante
verdad en el futuro cuando hablemos de
retorno sobre los activos de hecho ya
que lo dije vamos a hablar de eso
ahorita entonces supongamos que por
nuestro activo nos dan 10 millones o sea
que tenemos 10 millones en activo pues y
es que activo al menos según el estado
de resultados para 2008 dice que nos
está dando un millón de pesos cada año
en este año ganamos un millón entonces
nuestro retorno sobre los activos creo
que es un buen momento para introducir
lo nuestro roba por sus siglas en inglés
casi siempre se conoce como sus siglas
en inglés no te preocupes por traducirlo
entonces sería haber el numerador es el
retorno que es un millón de pesos y hay
que dividir entre la cantidad de activo
10 millones entonces eso es 10 por
ciento en retorno sobre los activos para
una inversión de 10 millones estamos
obteniendo un millón es decir estamos
obteniendo 10 por ciento de nuestro
activo cada año
bueno eso es una buena cosa para que te
acuerdes de esa después verdad el
retorno sobre activo está íntimamente
relacionado con la utilidad operativa y
con el activo de la compañía
pero bueno aprendimos en varios vídeos
especialmente en los de economía que no
todas las compañías están financiadas
igual muchas de ellas pueden tener este
deuda entonces supongamos que nuestra
compañía ejemplo me pago con cinco
millones en deuda por sus activos cinco
millones y supongamos que la tasa de
interés por ese préstamo es no se dejan
inventar algo bonito digamos un 5% y
vamos a decir que es de 5% no sabes que
dejando poner algo más bonito digamos
bueno si 5% dejémoslo en 5% todo más
fácil 10% perdón por no decidirme pero
esto de aquí es la utilidad operativa
este es el dinero que viene a partir del
activo pero por supuesto esto de ahí no
es el dinero que podemos llevarnos a la
casa porque también hay que pagar
interés por la deuda entonces déjame
ponerlo acá abajo
es esto de aquí es interés y bueno claro
si una compañía no tiene deudas no
tendría gastos en intereses verdad esto
de aquí es una un estado resultados
anual entonces vamos a ver de estos 5
millones de deuda en el año pagamos 10
por ciento diez por ciento de cinco
millones es 500 mil pesos entonces hay
que restar 500 mil pesos a la mitad de
nuestra utilidad operativa y dársela al
banco bueno ahora vamos a ver qué nos
queda nos quedan ya casi tenemos ya con
lo que sí nos podemos quedar pero este
es el ingreso antes de impuestos antes
de impuestos si restamos nos quedaría
500 mil pesos 500 mil pesos
y seguramente ya adivinaste cuál va a
ser el siguiente renglón verdad como
aquí dice antes de impuestos pues esto
de aquí es lo que obtienen los dueños de
la compañía antes de pagarle al gobierno
federal entonces aquí abajo sigue
impuestos pre supongamos que el impuesto
sobre la renta es de 30 por ciento y
entonces hay que pagar 30 por ciento de
este número de acá 30 por ciento de 500
mil 3 por 5 es 15 conocer los
correspondientes de 150 mil pesos 150
mil pesos muy bien listo terminamos
finalmente le pagamos a todo el mundo
que le teníamos que pagar verdad
empezamos acá arriba con 3 millones de
pesos
pagamos pagamos gastos gastos interés
banco lo que sea y nos queda es 350 mil
pesos 350 mil pesos de ingreso neto
ingreso neto esto de acá esto de acá es
lo que si va a los dueños de la compañía
este ingreso neto de acá muy bien
entonces regresando a nuestra hoja de
balance teníamos 10 millones en activos
5 millones en deuda 5 millones en pasivo
y lo que sobra debe de ser el capital
entonces déjame ponerlo en un color más
brillante así en verde y lo que queda
verdad era que es 10 millones supongamos
que todo es valor el libro que son 5
millones recuerda que código valor el
libro es una forma sofisticada de decir
que esto es lo que mis contadores dicen
que es lo que pagamos es lo que tenemos
escrito en los registros después vamos a
hablar de depreciación y amortización
cómo tenemos que cambiar el activo con
respecto a eso pero una forma sencilla
es que si compramos 10 millones pues
tenemos un activo de 10 millones y eso
queda en un libro si tenemos 5 millones
en deuda entonces lo que realmente nos
pertenece es 5 millones en capital
muy bien capital excelente ahora creo
que esto de aquí es algo interesante a
caribe hicimos retorno sobre activos
verdad nos fijamos en utilidad operativa
porque esto es lo que nuestra compañía
generó antes de pagarle al banco a
lolita oa cualquier otra persona
entonces este número de acá es el
numerador verdad y tenemos que dividir
entre la cantidad de activos pero ahora
vamos a fijarnos en otro coeficiente en
retorno sobre capital
entonces el retorno sobre capital roe
por sus siglas en inglés retorno sobre
capital en el numerador es ingreso neto
sería aquí 350 mil pesos y hay que
dividir pues entre qué creés entre el
capital entre el capital en libro
entonces es 5 millones 16 ceros se
cancelan los ceros este 0 también se va
es como 35 entre 535 entre 500 es lo
mismo que simplifican un 57 sobre 100 o
sea 7 por ciento tenemos un retorno
sobre capital de 7 por ciento y esto es
interesante porque debe o sea esto es
más pequeño verdad es un poco más bajo
ahorita no me voy a meter mucho en los
detalles porque creo que se me está
acabando
mi tiempo pero en este punto espero
haber explicado al menos las nociones
principales de un estado de resultados
básicos de una compañía que vende
artesanías después vamos a hacer otras
compañías financieras o de seguros o no
sé de líneas de gas natural lo que sea y
veremos que sus estados de resultados se
ven muy diferentes estén ambas con una
idea muy general pero espero que te
muestre como ingresos por ventas
utilidad neta utilidad por operación
ingreso antes de impuestos ingreso neto
son cosas realmente diferentes a veces
en los medios de comunicación la
revuelven entonces hay que darse cuenta
de que están hablando pero bueno nos
vemos